eles lembram como era a nossa vida antes
das redes sociais
esta é a imagem que para mim termos de
comunicação marchas malha ao que nós
vivia no chão antes de termos uma voz
nós já nos inundava os bombardeamentos
informações estavam sentados à noite com
a família é ver o telejornal e nos
intervalos tinham escovar com toda a
publicidade não temos como fugir
não chegamos com dizer que a tensão não
tem cão por favor não não obriguem
houver esse anúncio porque não vai
interessar este produto e no final as
marcas por seu lado também só tinham
resultado das vendas não sabiam se a
campanha tenha sido positivas as pessoas
tenham admirado o que eles tinham feito
em termos de comunicação se o produto
que era tão interessante como eu uso
tentavam fazer parceiros e depois
surgiram as redes sociais
assim que eu vejo que eu vivi eu
trabalho há 15 anos em comunicação e foi
isso um pouco o que o que eu vi
acontecer quando as redes sociais
surgiram nós nós somos o davi e
voltarmos controles simplesmente somos
os justiceiros somos os donos da bwa
sabemos qual é a solução para tudo
lembranças em 2013 quando caí um prêmio
no banco vez cheio de trabalhadores lá
dentro
nós voltamos não faz o contrário
condições de trabalho daquelas pessoas
não se lembram se
como nós nos voltamos também contra os
nossos políticos por eles não serem
corruptos eventualmente menos sérios e
prometerem coisas que depois não cumprem
mas com certeza sabe que nós defendemos
que o planeta tem que ser ver que temos
que tratar muito bem o nosso futuro
mas meu bar no mesmo dia em que
estávamos a postar a desgraça chorar as
vítimas daquele prédio porque o inglês
não conseguindo aumentarmos a felicitar
porque acabamos de comprar três ou
quatro partidas de tênis por 20 euros e
estamos muito contentes se a valorizar
não só nossos amigos da nossa nossa boa
compra
nesse mesmo dia houve um grupo de amigos
foram jantar lá em casa e esquecer um
espiral ichú mas foi o planeta verde e
também quando chegar a altura de
eleições de postarmos meses e meses e
meses a dizer o que a classe política
tem que fazer
não vamos pacto tem consistência que se
vive nas redes sociais e que se vive até
hoje para as marcas com quem trabalhava
era muito difícil de entender é muito
difícil chegar este consumidor entender
o que eu queria então com os sons que é
o trabalho que eu faço até hoje em dia é
o principal trabalho que fazemos é
tentar entender este consumidor com 111
monitorizando o que vai dizer nas redes
sociais analisando como ela vale as
campanhas entendendo qual é o design do
produto que eu posso que eu possa ter se
percebendo que querem fazer uma campanha
pra mim joana
sou mãe tenho três filhos com certeza
que produtos para crianças
eu sou um targa possível faço yoga um
tapetinho para fazer ioga também não é
mau porque nós vamos deixando as nossas
pegadas digitais como o nome falou vamos
deixando as redes sociais não só na
forma como nós nos apresentamos como que
nós defendemos nas idéias que nós temos
como nós que temos as marcas e como nós
nos relacionamos com elas
e aqui é que por ser o grande problema
na as marcas não estavam habituados a
isso as marcas não estavam habituadas a
trabalhar ea conversar com o consumidor
em tempo real em direito e à frente de
uma audiência
e esse trabalho o caminho
o que eu chamo caminho para a
humanização das marcas
foi um caminho muito complicado em que a
mim que cheguei que se entender o
consumidor através da mecanização mas
tinha que entender tamanha marca a marca
tinha que chegar certa forma uma pessoa
criar uma persona atrás dela
não fazia sentido estarmos nas redes
sociais havia lugar e eu perguntava por
exemplo eu a votar então este nosso
produto quantas calorias é que tenho no
facebook por exemplo uma marca dizer
estreitíssima senhora eu estou a falar
com a senhora joana que a filha
portanto tom de voz que era o
tradicional eo que temos uns 400 não se
adequava o novo maio são as redes
sociais
então o caminho para a humanização
passava identificar quem se esta marca
fosse uma pessoa quem é que seria e um
dos edifícios mais interessante que nós
tivemos uma empresa foi tentar arranjar
a persona de uma água tônica 1 água
tônica não pode ser simpática nas redes
sociais não é amarga e marga tem muito
gás
tá sempre um arrepio quando vemos nunca
poderia ser simpática então a persona
que nós encontramos foi o doctor house
o doctor house é quem nós passamos a
toda a gente que faz o atendimento uma
marca porque quando se faz o atendimento
nas redes sociais esse atendimento é
feito por várias pessoas e cada uma
delas com sua personalidade com sua
maneira de ser e que tem ainda que o
espaço que trabalhar uma marca defendê
lo e apresentá lo de uma forma mais ou
menos homogénea
não faz sentido eu ser o doctor house
hoje a das novas 5 e depois entrou o meu
colega washington à meia noite
de repente uma simpatia uma cristina
ferreira portanto esse trabalho de
personalização das marcas foi um
trabalho que não não estava à espera
fazer que morou muito tempo até ser
entendível mas que aos poucos foi
fazendo
e tudo isto devendo o que estava a dizer
nas redes sociais e mesmo as campanhas
toda a gente vai conhecer esta imagem se
vocês repararem no que queiram as
campanhas eu lembro das campanhas da
benetton
anos 90 que eram aquelas campanhas
machucavam mundo
a sida é morte raças discussão raças por
aí fora
tivemos 20 anos do guia em que a imagem
que temos é que pessoas felizes
é tudo muito bem disposto e esta
comunicação para massas com um riff beco
da poeira fácil vamos ser todos frisa
mar
eles compraram o produto vai ficar assim
em tão feliz como eu tô aqui agora com
as redes sociais já não cola mãe porque
nós vamos ao nosso time e tudo o que
vemos são histórias de vida
tudo que nós o que nos motiva são suas
família valores nós próprios a
autoestima por aí fora e por isso é que
temos a ver cada vez mais campanhas com
estas que tocam solidão que tocam o
divórcio toca à família por fora tudo
isso vai ver do que nós próprios estamos
interessados e nós estamos a fazer parte
desta máquina nos produtos de tóxico
também frisa sem açúcar sem lactose
multivitaminas com figuras biológicos
genéticos free em milhares de produtos a
vez de anos atrás tínhamos no limite o
normal e light
isso é um reflexo do que nós vamos
pedindo do que nós vamos exigindo com
consumidores
isso não vai parar de crescer no limite
vamos ter um produto que vai chamar da
joana em breve porque nós temos a fazer
parto tudo por seis cise vivo de tudo o
que as marcas estão a fazer se traga
mais alguns exemplos nós exigimos tudo
que seja fai tenho meu time
trabalho com pós produção cada vez menos
apreciadas campanhas muito trabalhadas
jogos passam ao lado já sabemos que é
possível fazer coisas fantásticas mas
fantástico mesmo olverbeck sites é ver o
que se passou por trás e perceber como é
que se com aquela ideia isso que nos
motiva e sei que nos liga uma marca é
que nos faz apaixonar-se eo meu time é
bom tem sido rápido precisamos acelerar
informação em tempo real nós próprios
temos capacidade seprotur da informação
em tempo real portanto tudo isto e muito
exigentes para marcas e consumidores
eu gosto particularmente este exemplo
exemplo é um exemplo de convivência
informação com as marcas também tem que
ser desenhada à medida dos interesses do
consumidor
ontem vi essa notícia que dizia só que o
ovo banana
queria ver se a próxima temporada do
grêmio frontes instou a agência
eu tinha uma opção ou ia saber em
detalhe o que aconteceu que se ao icann
no lado esquerdo ou parceria frente e
verso
claro que fiquei curiosa e fui perceber
o que aconteceu cada vez que eu vou
fazendo isto
cada vez mais esta ap vai me dar votos
do que me interessa e hoje em dia quase
não vejo desporto não ligo muito futebol
por aí fora
fui rejeitado sempre esse tipo de
comunicação e ao jato foi da minha vida
porque eu já tenho na minha mão é
informação que é relevante para mim para
é mim para os meus interesses lançar
terça fora
as marcas têm de estar onde o consumidor
está em visitava e este é um caso o faz
porque é que eu vou lançar a
possibilidade nós chamamos um táxi
encomendamos uma pizza comprar umas
sapatilhas fazemos tudo que fizemos pelo
messenger
são 900 milhões de pessoas no mês em dia
ninguém mais vai deslocar para um site
procurados o que seja cada vez estamos
mais preguiçosos mais exigentes e seus
produtos não venham ter connosco nós
porque simplesmente se devíamos atenção
para o tema e foi isso que foi lançado a
partir de muito brevemente será possível
encomendar em uma pizza parte do
messenger dizem querer uma causa zona
com queijo e fiambre e pagam
automaticamente ea pizza por ser nossa
casa
o whatsapp cada vez mais o conceito de
marcas a prestarem serviço ao consumidor
este é um exemplo que eu gosto ostenta
um exemplo de uma marca de maquiagem que
tem um serviço de atendimento ao
consumidor que ajuda as mulheres
querem as mulheres ou os maridos
quiserem o francês produtos para ficarem
mais bonitas
basta subir a vossa imagem que tem do
outro lado um consultor de imagem que
vai dizer ah não posso tanto pela como é
mais morenas cada um batom mais maio
fora vai caminhar por último em
antecipação
quem tem um apoio lotes já percebeu que
se ficar muito tempo sentado após o
outro vai dizer que está em vantagem e
tem que fazer um passeio porque faz mal
tanto tempo sentado
isso é o que já acontece mas muito em
breve
é possível que eu já aqui e do vale
nerds uma mensagem a dizer
joana são quatro anos acho muito mal vai
perceber isso a minha pulsação por
tentar horas visado valeu faz um
desconto ficamos numa pracinha
isto é possível acontecer em breve
portanto como eu vai ju o nosso mundo
agora é completamente enfrenta que ela
cascata que tínhamos aquela avalanche
estrago que tínhamos até agora no fundo
agora transformou neste mar mais treino
em todos nós somos afluentes todos nós
temos a contribuir
todos nós temos a participar nesta
mudança das marcas e do mundo
inevitavelmente portanto por volta